lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es dar
un resumen rápido de las distintas
maneras en las que las células se pueden
comunicar entre ellas y tal vez la más
básica es sólo a través de con
tú
y cree
y esto puede pasar de varias maneras
distintas una manera puede ser solo
tener células vecinas entonces esto es
una célula justo aquí y esta es la
célula vecina justo aquí en realidad
ellas pueden tener huecos en sus
membranas si fueran células animales
llamaríamos a estos huecos uniones gap
dibujé dos de ellas y este es obviamente
un corte en dos dimensiones por lo que
no se aprecia completamente la
estructura tridimensional pero la idea
básica es que tal vez la célula de la
izquierda empieza a producir ciertas
moléculas
especialmente moléculas pequeñas que
pueden pasar por estas uniones gap y
cuando pueden pasar a través de estas
uniones gap tal vez se adhieren a
algunas proteínas en la segunda célula
que podrían activarlas de alguna manera
inhibir las de alguna manera o provocar
algún tipo de reacción entonces tenemos
una res
pues
en la segunda célula entonces esto es
una forma de comunicación algo sucedió
en esta primera célula que produjo estas
moléculas estas moléculas pudieron
entrar a la segunda célula y generar una
respuesta y como mencioné si estas son
células animales llamaríamos a estos
huecos uniones gamma
entonces esto justo aquí es una unión
gap
nyon
hemos visto esto en otros vídeos
y si hablamos de células de plantas
podemos ver que ocurren cosas muy
similares pero no las llamamos uniones
gap éstos serían huecos no solamente
serían túneles a través de la membrana
celular también serían a través de la
pared celular si fueran plantas serían
plasmó decimos
moss
y hemos hablado más de ellos en vídeos
de la estructura celular pero hay otras
maneras de comunicación a través de
contacto directo puedes imaginar algunas
células que están flotando en el
torrente sanguíneo tal vez esta es una
célula justo aquí y tal vez ésta es otra
célula justo aquí y tienen proteínas de
superficie complementarias proteínas de
superficie que pueden enlazarse entre
ellas tal vez ésta tiene una proteína de
superficie que se ve así
obviamente estoy exagerando su forma la
proteína no se vería exactamente como
este triángulo invertido pero esta tiene
su pared proteica así también estoy
exagerando el tamaño relativo a la
célula solo para poder apreciar cómo
podrían unirse entonces ésta tiene una
proteína de superficie así cuando se
juntan entre ellas pueden cambiar las
proteínas de alguna manera y provocar
una reacción en cada una de las células
tal que la comunicación entonces
continúe si esta proteína cambia un poco
podría activar algo podría activar la
liberación de algunas moléculas podría
activar a otras proteínas podría
catalizar algún tipo de reacción hemos
visto esto en muchos otros vídeos todo
tipo de reacciones biológicas locas
pueden suceder dentro de las células
pero podrían provocar una
res
pues
e incluso podrían provocar una respuesta
en ambas células algún tipo de res
pues
safin que están fuertemente unidas a
otra célula ahora contacto directo como
puedes imaginar no es la única forma de
tener comunicación celular también
podrías tener células que empiezan a
comunicarse a partir de una distancia
pequeña liberando moléculas en el
espacio extracelular y luego llegarán al
torrente sanguíneo
entonces por ejemplo déjame dibujar una
célula por aquí y tal vez puede producir
ciertas moléculas
pueden ser solubles en lípidos y pueden
hacerse camino a través de la membrana
celular por sí mismas o tal vez están
empaquetadas en vesículas que les
permiten atravesar la membrana
entonces cuando la membrana de la
vesícula se une a la membrana celular
permite que estas moléculas
salga
entonces puedes imaginar que si otra
célula tiene los receptores correctos
para estas moléculas eso podría estar
dando cierto tipo de respuesta o
produciendo cierto tipo de comunicación
entonces digamos que tengo bueno déjame
dibujar un par de células digamos que
tengo esta célula aquí y que tengo esta
otra aquí y digamos que esta célula
tiene el receptor correcto y esta célula
no
puede tener otros receptores tal vez
receptores como este pero no es el
correcto entonces estas moléculas que
fueron liberadas por la primera célula
no podrían unirse a esta proteína de
superficie pero a estas y entonces se
pueden unir a este receptor
lo que hace entonces esta proteína que
está en la membrana celular es que puede
cambiar su forma puede hacer todo tipo
de cosas pero esa señal puede adquirirse
de alguna manera puede continuar su
camino al interior de la célula y una
vez más se puede obtener una respuesta
respuesta
mencionaré con más detalles en futuros
vídeos como sucede esto exactamente o
qué respuestas pueden ocurrir en
realidad ahora si esto es una distancia
corta
esta es una distancia corta
estancia
corta podríamos llamarla para clint a
esto sería parte del sistema para trino
o podríamos llamarlo comunicación para
tren a déjame escribirlo
tema
era
no o comunicación para karina o
señalización para crina y llamaríamos a
estos factores para chrinos pero si
sucediera a través de una distancia
larga
digamos que estas moléculas entran al
torrente sanguíneo entonces se abren
paso en el torrente sanguíneo justo aquí
déjame representar de alguna manera que
este es el torrente sanguíneo entonces
este es el torrente sanguíneo
rehn
guineo
y son capaces de recorrer el torrente
sanguíneo a lo largo de distancias
mayores hacia otras moléculas entonces
tal vez ésta tiene los receptores
correctos para esas moléculas entonces
llamaríamos a este sistema endocrino o
bien señalización endocrina
entonces para una distancia larga en una
sea
larga
se llamaría sistema endocrino o
señalización endocrina
acción
en doctrina
y estamos hablando del sistema endocrino
y señalización endocrina y estas
moléculas que podrían ser cualquier tipo
de molécula podrían ser esteroides
podrían ser proteínas de algún tipo en
este caso la llamaremos hormonas
probablemente has escuchado esa palabra
antes y haremos toda una serie de vídeos
sobre hormonas
pero estas moléculas pueden afectar
incluso a la célula que las produjo por
ejemplo la célula que las produjo puede
tener el receptor correcto entonces si
es capaz de dar señales de provocar una
reacción en sí misma entonces si éstas
son capaces de provocar una reacción en
sí mismas llamamos a este proceso
autocrítico auto cree
está actuando por sí mismo y solo para
que te familiarices con algo de la
terminología estas proteínas en la
superficie que es el caso en particular
si tienes factores de comunicación o
moléculas no solubles en lípidos justo
aquí estas proteínas si están en la
superficie o incluso si están dentro de
la célula las llamaremos receptores
entonces esto justo aquí es un receptor
el sector
y las moléculas por sí mismas estas
cosas que se enlazan al receptor las
llamamos ligando
gan
normalmente es un término general de
algo que se une al receptor y entonces
en ese punto donde se une al receptor ya
sea que hablemos del proceso para trino
o del proceso endocrino de la
señalización endocrina este proceso
donde se enlaza al receptor llamado
percepción de señal y cuando esta
proteína de alguna manera cambia su
forma o cataliza una reacción o inhibe
una reacción lo llamamos transducción de
señal
trans tú
se refiere a llevar la señal al interior
de la célula y después se obtiene una
respuesta celular espero que lo hayas
apreciado es solo un pequeño resumen de
cómo las células pueden comunicarse
entre ellas en los próximos vídeos
entraremos más en detalles especialmente
en el sistema endocrino y nuestro
entendimiento de las hormonas